a riot broke out in Cardiff last night
at the scene of a road traffic collision
a footage shared on social media showed
rioters throwing missiles and fireworks
on a road in Ely while police attempted
to de-escalate what they described as
large-scale disorder in a statement
South Wales police say arrests are being
made and a large police presence remains
in the area
well let's cross to our correspondent
Molina bethleinovich morning to you
Milena what more can you tell us about
this
good morning well what we know for
certain is that police officers were
called to the scene of this serious road
traffic collision at about 6 p.m last
night and this Collision seems to have
sparked off unrest in the area that
turned into a full-blown Riot and we
could see social media footage of uh
gangs of youths really who many of them
wearing masks throwing would look like
fireworks flares missiles at the police
who were wearing uh riot shields now we
also know that a couple of cars were
also set Ablaze shortly after midnight
the police also said that a member of
the public was attacked because the
rioters thought that they were part of
an undercover policing operation now
police on horses were also seen guarding
the ELO police station because there was
some fear that it might be attacked and
this was a very long running disorder
that took the best part of the night a
variety on the streets at 3M what we
don't know for certain is what sparked
this disorder